[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring the question what are our
greatest physical feats and I don't mean
like which of our feet are bigger
because my left foot is a little bit
bigger than my right foot in fact a
half-size bigger than my right foot that
seems like it could be a problem yes my
greatest physical foot is my left foot
it's a size it's like a size twelve
point two and my right foot is like a
size eleven point seven seven okay
mm-hmm so I just get twelve and call it
even call it a day now actually one of
my feet is bigger than the other foot
two because back when we along with the
help of all of the mythical beasts at
the time we designed a shoe that we
didn't sold I don't know if you knew
this called the mythical shoe and when
you start to make your own shoe it was
basically like a it was a fabulous
converse ripoff shoe I mean it had we
and had a wing embroidered on the canvas
and had a we threw a lot of that shoe it
had a guitar pick holster yeah and it
will shoot I still love the that was
like a nice tasteful black and white but
then there was also like a oh my gosh
look away blue and green that was the
fun pair then we made all anyway I
digress but when you find yourself just
a heads up whenever you find yourself
making your own branded shoe as as you
will you'll find that you have the
luxury of getting them to fit exactly
how you want and I found out that one of
my feet is bigger than the other one -
do you know which one cuz I'm like oh I
want to I wanted a ten-and-a-half in one
foot and at 11 in the other one but
which one is your left foot can't
remember I can't remember cuz once I ran
out of those shoes I'm like I got to
forget that happened I don't have that
luxury mine is noticeable like with any
pair of shoes that I try oh that's why I
always just try on the left to shoot at
shoe stores and then wear to socks on
the right no it's not that big of a
difference it's just like if the left
foot fits I know the right foot is gonna
fit also my left arm is longer than my
right arm probably by like
a quarter to a third of an inch so much
so that like when I get measured for
like a fitted shirt there they have to
measure it differently really my left
one of my eyes is a little bit bigger
than the other which one is it
the left one the left one yeah my whole
left side of the body I think that the
eye opening is bigger the eyeball is
probably this eyeball it's the same size
yeah I think there's other things that
but interestingly always look like
you're about to wink all the injuries
not that bad all the injuries are on the
right side of my body my elbow my wrist
my shoulder my hip and my knee
all right side the weak side man but I'm
right-handed isn't this weird I don't
know if it's weird so we are gonna talk
about our greatest physical feats oh and
did you happen to notice what what a
little-little what jingle around my neck
this is not how olympic medalists if
that's what you're what you are you got
it you got it you gotta learn to wear
them where the prize is in style and we
continue to try to teach you to this to
win with some sort of decorum but when
like I expected it yes why'd this act
like you've been there before us Josh
young told you after you scored a goal
one time two goals in one game yeah I
mean if you're not watching the video
version of this I'll be happy to fill
you in on the fact that I am sporting
around my thick muscular neck the weight
is 15 and a half inch net the weight of
a hefty physical feat completed and that
is Iran in a Spartan Race and I got a
medal I got a medal I'm wearing it never
I got a I got a I got a Science Olympiad
medal once I will I will note that you
just turned it around and it just said
finisher on it so I mean it yeah which
is I'm I didn't get a place but hey you
know what you finished I didn't even do
it I finished you didn't even start I
don't even start it on the back there's
a third of another medal that if I
complete apparently two more Spartan
races in this calendar year
I get a Big Daddy trifecta medal a smart
marketing man yeah yes especially a
collector you definitely want to get the
other two pieces of that right I don't
even know how but I'm probably already
signing uh so lanes gonna tell us about
his his experience with the Spartan Race
and then we're gonna talk about some
other physical feats but I do and I will
say that I discovered just a little more
of a tease something happened that I did
not anticipate that I think is gonna
have a forever impact on Who I am
okay I'm my interest is piqued
what is it peaked with a queue okay I am
going to answer some questions that have
been lingering out there if those of you
who follow my very dynamic Instagram
account read em see also the same name
of my very dynamic an awesome Twitter
account read em see shout out to both of
those accounts I encourage you to follow
both of them for enrichment right and if
you want to complete the set let's just
shout out to link Lamont on Instagram
that's right very active very active
very very active now like a like a like
when the Amish go and sow their Wild
Oats that active whoa you know how they
have a year they can do that better
protect yourself I don't know what they
call it but it's where they can sow
their Wild Oats I think that's why they
call it but then they called the devil's
year I'm that active on Instagram I
posted this video to both accounts I
thought it deserved that kind of
exposure yes I need and I haven't gotten
the complete download again if you can't
download I've heard pieces Instagram
videos yes right you're talking about
the cat yeah yes you may have seen that
I posted a video about a minute long
video of a night-vision camera focused
on the couch in my living room which is
actually a cropped version of the what
of the bigger video oh nice you did some
crowd I wanted to draw your eye to the
cat and I said something like see this
cat on my couch at 3 a.m. here's the
thing we don't have a cat
don't-don't-don't and I left it at that
apparently that was incredibly strategic
because it was like my most liked post
ever how many how many life I think at
the time that we're recording this I
think is it it's been seen like almost
three hundred thousand times on their
Twitter or Instagram or both I don't
know which is a lot for a video on those
platforms for me I think I need to know
an exact number if I'm gonna compare it
to my return to Instagram okay how many
likes does that have Alex I think you
blew me out of the water okay but that's
views oh that's views no no no likes
yeah because people don't usually like
videos as much as as watch them okay
yeah
that's D that's a decent number it's not
what I got when I when I you know when I
came back well I think that the real
comparison should be your watermelon
outfit picture to my watermelon outfit
picture
so listen oh yeah now something tells me
it's breda something tells me you've
done this because I can see the glimmer
in your eye no no I just course I
haven't done it I haven't done it 117
thousand likes on retz watermelon okay
and by the time that this is oh wait a
you will have surpassed me oh yeah by
the time that on the air airwaves ya
mind still on the upward trend okay but
anyway that's all you wrote on your
Instagram caption but there was more to
the story as Paul Harvey is that his
name
we used to say everybody loves Paul
Harvey the rest of the story yeah he
said the rest is story not there's more
to the story the real story is not as
exciting as Satan manifested himself as
a cat in my living room because that's
what I wanted you to think okay it did
not happen as far as I know what
happened was because I also don't make a
habit of just like watching my you know
looking at my couch all night long
through the video through going back to
the archives yeah how would you even I
woke up I walked downstairs as I do when
I wake up oh it was this the middle of
the night or the morning this was the
morning okay and the front
or was just wide open and I knew that I
was the first person downstairs oh no I
knew I was the only person awake and so
I was like okay that means that this
door has been open all night I mean like
open and like come on in like friends a
gate yeah and so I did what we do in my
house when you encounter a problem I
immediately tried to figure out who to
blame and so I knew that Locke had had
friends over the night before and so I
yelled upstairs Locke did your friends
leave the door open I think your friends
left the door open last night he was
open all night
and he yelled back no dad
a healthy communicate I was a medic in
the McLaughlin household or was he was
that point-blank range and you just yell
like that or yeah he was right next okay
and then I said well I'm gonna check the
video camera footage you didn't believe
him so I went into the archives that I
can access via my phone and I started to
because basically if you zoom out that
that that image of the couch to the far
left is the front door it's sort of the
it's the living room and the front door
cam that gets it okay yeah and I kind of
scrubbing through but I'm kind of
scrubbing through ham-handed Lee so that
I accidentally like scrubbed all the way
to 3:00 a.m.
whoops and then like I see this little
dot well did you see that the door had
been left open well yeah okay so just
giving forward and then I'll come back I
did see that it was his friends who left
it was did you yell at him then yeah you
were distracted by I was focused on the
cat at this point okay go ahead but they
walked out and they pulled the door too
but it didn't close all the way and then
it was like a windy night so it just
blew the door open okay but what I saw
was that little black dot and then it
took a lot I had to like it takes a lot
to get back to this a specific little
minute you know
right cuz I'm like cuz there's like an
eight-hour video that's a freaking cat a
cat came in the and first I thought is
that a raccoon and some people still
think that they see a raccoon tonight
it's very hard to tell and there is a
family of raccoons that lives in the lot
next to me like literally a family one
time I saw the mom she was walking
across the fence next to the pool and
three baby raccoons were following her
that's cute and also if you listen to
the to the video you'll see that at the
end after the cat disappears sort of
behind the wall there's a like a
repeated sound of like somebody taking
like a cord and like hitting against the
floor which that's a very raccoon thing
to do yeah not cats don't make that cats
don't leave a mark you know they're like
evil spirits they just float through
spaces they don't step heavy and stuff
like that so in the video they're gonna
I do think they get the cat jumps off
the couch behind the couch no no it
comes to the edge of the couch which is
behind behind the wall kind of the
corner of the room where there's like
that light and then like that the camera
view was obstructed and he did something
I don't know what it was but I'm 90%
sure it was a cat and and and it's a
black cat that I think is a neighbor's
cat that is kind of around then we don't
feed cats I don't believe in feeding
cats as a policy I believe that some cat
should be fed I'm not saying that you
know obviously I don't feed cat you
don't believe in you feeding cats and
it's a neighbor's cat that's one of
those roving cats yeah if you feed it
it'll keep coming back and so apparently
he just thought it was okay to come
inside apparently he didn't understand
the disposition of her household towards
cats because you didn't did you see the
cat exit or if not did you think the
camp may still be in the house no I
thought he had probably gone I thought
he had left at that point you were
thinking about an Instagram post oh yeah
you were you had moved on from lot being
wrong and you being right and from a cat
being there - how do i exploit this
digitally yeah yeah and when that was
when my wife and I had the conversation
about
um cuz I think she was she was like oh I
should tweet that or something
Oh am i wool I should tweet that well
it's a China out Tweety or because I'm
like well you know I just I think that
my post has the most potential okay
but she did you give her their line you
can retweet my tweet oh she did she did
she did come up with some of the verbage
that she I think she came up with here's
the thing we don't have a cat it was it
was a collective - she's your
ghostwriter yeah she's my ghostwriter
and so it's also like just the other day
it's funny because now that she's on
Twitter I mean she's got an Instagram
account that's you know prize well she's
got one that's like a herd like design
thing that's public and then she's got
one that's herself for this private but
Twitter of course is just public for
everybody so like she's she's kind of
getting into the fray a little bit okay
and so now when things happen at home
there's a little bit of a race like so
my most like tweet ever as of this
weekend was my I was like Jesse a
shepherd she said what kind of eggs do
you want and he said pancakes
he's got like 20 something thousand
likes I just tweeted my wife to my ten
year old what kind of eggs do you want
10 year old pancakes people just love
that you had no role in that except
tweeting yeah right and so and as soon
as it happened I was like that's a good
tweet and it's funny because you know
Jesse was actually in she she was part
of the tweet but she didn't we
recognized it was funny at the time but
she didn't immediately think I got a
tweet there oh and and and so she lost
yeah but she could she commented on it
it's an interesting thing because when
what was the comment like hey this
should have been my tweet no she says
she made it she made a joke about eggs
or pancakes I can't actually go on I
liked it
she glommed on and you liked it I but
it's funny because I don't I don't tweet
that much you know we've talked about
this I'm all for that now right I'm on
to the new thing
new thing called Instagram but um
britain who now lives with us
he started tweeting things that are set
around my house oh so he's doing that so
he's he's doing what you're doing he's
like listening in this stuff in the Neal
household and then tweeted like stuff
that's Christie saying he's clean
there's a treasure trove there yeah but
I course I can't do that you know I
can't be the one it's like here's
something my wife said implying like
you'll find this layer I follow Britain
on Twitter but I'm I haven't followed
him closely enough to know to see these
tweets that you speak of I don't follow
me there no I do but I do follow him but
I'm just saying I don't know I just look
at moments and mentions right I don't
see a lot of what cuz what he told me
another thing my wife says she's like I
walk home she I walk home I walk in in
home and she says you didn't like my
tweet oh no I didn't see your freaking
twit I'm sorry oh I like it now
dang yeah yeah it's only if she thinks
that her tweet was deserving of a like
and it often is but I haven't seen these
Britain tweets so how many times has he
done this and it does he say my how does
he how does he have that's right he's
tried out this catchphrase it's like
he'll he'll say he'll give the exchange
and then he'll say something like
another day in the Neal household or
something hashtag another day in the new
house something like that it got
shortened that he's you know I'm letting
him do his own experimentation even
though I am an expert in Twitter you
know Who am I am I to give him advice on
the on the tweeting okay so that's the
story it's not as exciting as you might
it's still a little bit exciting but it
was just as simple as leaving the door
open you know fun fact if you leave your
door open animals and or people I mean I
should be happy that it was just a cat
yeah not a cat burglar and that the cat
left I mean you could be taking care of
a cat right now well I wouldn't be I
would have escorted it out okay all
right we're gonna get into my race and
what happened and how my life was
potentially changed or not but first we
want to just encourage you to buy some
stuff from us I mean let's be real
we're selling stuff you can rep it
mythical dot
once you grab that hat though as hats
cuz I've got a hat in my hand we're not
gonna wear them because when he would do
that
well Lynx wearing is I have a tan hat
works great over a set of cans put it
over your cans
after euphemism for headphones this is
the way this is the way the kids are
wearing hats now it's just lightly
lightly placed on automatically Wow look
how big my head looks wanna do that and
your head can look this big - got a
mythical dot store get that and all
types of other stuff bigger head bigger
brain your head bigger brain okay link
tell us about your experience spoiler
alert I got a metal I don't I don't know
if I pointed that out earlier but I got
it I mean it is a heavy metal like hold
your hand out yeah it makes you feel
like you did something a substantial man
reminds me of when we made medals for
our super note competition the arguably
the largest youtube collaboration slash
competition to date to that date at
least that's what we call it at least
that's what we say that's how we
marketed it it was a true or not it was
a competition to see who could hold out
the longest continuous vocal note on the
internet we should bring that back gosh
it was a different world now it's a
different internet world anyway we made
metals like this but this one's pretty
freakin cool oh you want this hat out
which one Rhett's fault so I go to a gym
and they're doing things like a lot of
people at my gym they'll get on Facebook
and they're like talk to each other and
encourage each other and there's a
there's it and of course I don't do that
encouragement I'm encouragement for
losers I'm there for the burpees I'm
there for the tonnage I'm there I'm
there - I'm there to just get fit I mean
the first thing that got me into the gym
three years ago now ish was I was having
shoulder problems I was having knee
problems I went to physical therapy they
taught me some exercises
then made me feel better but I was like
I gotta maintain my body I got I got to
turn a corner here so I started going to
the gym but I'm not one of these people
that's like I'm just I'm doing this for
me I'm doing this for my health I'm
doing it for my wife and kids you know
to to be physically a part of their
lives you know I think I know it
[Laughter]
you want to be around you want to be
engaged you want to be surprised yeah I
want to be able to grab them and toss
them you want to be young at heart and
in body yeah man and not get hurt
arm wrestle that kind of thing show him
who's boss but the social aspect of it
was not really my thing so I'm not
really I mean I know people I have
friends at the gym but you know at the
end of last year I'm thinking there's
some things that I'm I just I'm trying
to be more open to even more experience
especially when it relates to self-care
and I think those two things coming
together led me very early on at the top
of the year as I was leaving the gym the
guy just mentioned hey there's a sign up
for the Spartan Race and I'd heard of
this and some people had done it before
and they and a lot of people signed up
they do it as a group from the gym and I
didn't really think about I was like I'm
gonna do that I looked at the date I
knew we weren't out of town and I just
signed up it was kind of like I was in
observing myself make a decision that I
wouldn't never thought I would make it
was like an out-of-body experience I was
like I'm doing this I don't I don't know
why I'm just I'm gonna give it a shot
you know I'm open now I'm more
interested in me I don't know what this
I don't know what's involved in this
race and then the next time I got to the
gym I was like maybe you should tell me
a little bit about this thing that I'm
gonna be doing this Spartan Race it was
like well we don't train here we'd say
you got to come Sunday mornings first
thing we're gonna meet out at a park and
we're gonna do like special training for
it I'm like okay you got to run a 5k and
there's 20 obstacles all along the way
and there's there's a Spartan Race
there's a Tough Mudder there's all types
of things floating or
found that I've heard about but I'm like
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go to the
training I'll see what how this shapes
up I didn't really look on the website I
made up my mind I didn't I didn't want
to like look at the obstacles or really
try to understand what's happening cuz I
didn't want to I thought like I'll get
nervous so I'm just gonna go to the to
the training on that Sunday morning but
the obstacles that were gonna be they
weren't gonna replicate the obstacles in
this park not to it not to an exact
degree right no when we went to the park
there was just a small group of us like
six of us and the trainer guy ran to the
obstacles change each year they change
from from location to location yeah so
you don't really know what you're
getting into this part of it yeah but I
didn't even want to know like generally
I knew there was mud involved and they
talked about like crawling under barbed
wire okay and I get there and it's just
a park there's no obstacles at all I
mean it's just there's a dog park over
here and then there's a regular park
over here and so we have to pair up and
this start running a lap around this
part off there's no it just on the dirt
and then whenever we would come back
around we get down and we start crawling
on the dirt and like he had some bags
and we'd carry some bags or we do
burpees but he was Tomac now you got to
get low and this is how you do an army
crawl just imagine as a barbed wire over
top of him like dang am I gonna look
bleedin at this thing well if you don't
get low enough I think it like Tough
Mudder they Jenna was telling me they
like shock you and stuff it was not a
doubt for the Spartan the Spartan Race
is not the Tough Mudder gets up to is
not as crazy they all have different
levels but the the most the moat the
highest Tough Mudder is like a Tough
Mudder yeah so this you don't get
shocked but you do get dirty and you get
down you get down in it so like I'm
learning how to do an army crawl in the
middle of this park and that's not easy
you got to have good hip mobility mm to
stay low and I'm I'm crawling around on
my belly and all of a sudden
here somebody say what are you guys up
to and they said oh we're training for a
Spartan Race and then I'm crawling up to
this guy and he's like walking his dog
heckling us and he's like you pay you to
crawl around in your belly out here like
that and I'm like I wanted to say
something very nasty to him I bit my
tongue I didn't say anything she trying
to make conversation and then I'm like
his dog is crappy
you pay for your dog to crap like that
and then I would have made a bag come
back and so here I am crawling I'm
crawling there's like dog crap obstacles
oh thank you sir hey can I keep Kenny
humiliating now it's kind of like
second-guessing my decision and then we
start running and I realize I am
horrible running like the I know how to
move my legs like a runner but it's
something about the breathing part of it
that it's extremely difficult for me
like I was out of breath man I was
struggling I learned this when we ran
the mile yes in our old studio in a very
small circle and I thought that you were
joking I thought that you the trouble
that you were having with it was part of
it was a bit I think I have asthma I
mean I don't want to make lighter asthma
I just can't breathe when I start
running I think it's a I I think it's a
rhythm thing yeah I mean I was asking
about it like my trainer was like you
never breathing deeply enough yeah you
got a you know the breathe in through
your nose breathe out through your mouth
I remember back when we were like in
Little League baseball we'd have to like
run laps around there and like it's like
breathe in through your nose breathe out
the mouth and I'm just like so I'm we
paired up because in there there's a
woman who had a French accent
his name was blonde Dean was like a
graphic novel stars I've been like
blonde Dean Blondin the French woman
became my workout partner so I'm running
it we started that's the best name great
person I've ever heard great person I
might have a daughter just so I can have
a blondie I'm gonna get my vasectomy
reversed
gonna go to one of those specialists
that can that can put your sperm in a
centrifuge to make sure that only the
female sperm or whatever you call it
get in there I'm gonna have a girl so I
can name her blondie
where'd it right and you need to set it
set the spin cycle to French so she
comes out speaking French oh gosh I
thought I'd be done it's 20 is it 19 you
know what I never asked her to speak to
me in French oh good but she has an
accent she's very nice person her and
her husband own like these gyms for kids
you know how when you like take your kid
to this place and there might be
trampolines and obstacles and crap so
like a jump center yes so she's like
athletic minded and we start running and
I'm like oh she's set in the pace that's
like and I'm like.he and gotta keep up a
blonde very early I'm like I'm not good
at running I don't think I know how to
breathe right and then a few of like it
like three minutes later I couldn't talk
anymore
so it was like I couldn't object I just
had to like really try to run to keep up
with her she's your partner though so
it's just it's not that she was running
fast it's just that she was running at a
decent pace right and I don't know how
to do that right from a from a breathing
point it could be in your legs too maybe
your legs aren't moving the right way
you may have an inefficient stroke I
thought I had I achieved fatigue pretty
quickly but I pushed through just like
it says on the back of my metal push
harder okay almost on the back and when
when you get really fatigued it's hard
to run and I found myself falling we're
running on the dirt falling behind or
falling like falling on my face like
falling like she was running a little
bit ahead it was a little bit of a
decline it was like dirt and gravel ish
type scenario and whenever she would hit
a little dip and then it would go down
and up she she'd get some momentum so
he's like woo up and so she could get up
the other side I wasn't great at that
either and I felt like oh if it weren't
for my hands catching me I would have
fallen flat on my face
and like my knees bleeding and she's
like are you okay I'm like I'm not good
at running and I get up I'm like running
the rest and then so I had a war wound
so come back the next week and I got a I
got a knee brace a knee brace over my
knee wound okay because my knee was also
hurting after that on the inside and the
outside and then I'm running the next
time and Blondie's not there cuz she had
to go to France yeah for qualities so
I'm running with Lois quarterly trip to
frame Lois is even faster than Blonde
Dean I'm trying to keep up with him just
like sucking air we're coming down we're
running up in the woods we're coming
down from the woods on a on that the
decline and he's well ahead of me so
he's stopping to do our burpees and as
he turns around and looks I give him a
show like I splayed out and just felling
him on my hands and my knees I'm just
like just tumbling down this hill all
because I'm so I can't run I'm that
tired like I get so tired like my feet
wouldn't lift over the dirt and he's
like uh you don't know what to say in
that instance to the guy to the guys
like you're training with this guy and
he's like you okay man and I'm like yeah
I did this last week I did this with
blonde Dean so then the next week I show
up I got a knee brace on both knees you
need like a full body suit that I mean
like a Kevlar three-piece suit I need to
be true I need to look like somebody
that you do motion-capture what you need
is you need like a four-wheeler just to
ride and follow a few I need to begin
efficient I got a helmet and I got a
combustible engine that propels me yeah
so I became I just developed this
reputation amongst the group of being
the guy who like is gonna bleed every
time the falling bleeder needless to say
I come race today I was pretty nervous
right like that didn't affect my sleep
because you know I'm whenever my head is
the pillow I'm just I did I get stupid
I'm a stupid sleeper so I'm blessed with
that but when I woke
man I'm kind of nervous we had to drive
out to Chino or Chico or what Chino yeah
you got to know which one you're going
to a lot of people out there I might oh
I get to see these obstacles and
everything and despite a lot of falling
bleeders out there too I had on both of
my my knee braces they gave a sock so we
could all look the same and liked it so
I got these like tube socks on my shins
and I got a headband I always wear a
headband by the way that's my signature
every time I work out I gotta there's
always one in every gym I'm that guy
yeah the guy with a headband so I
usually don't talk to him but I would
talk to you
blonde Dean and I take off the race
starts and I'm like okay I can I can do
this I caught a glimpse of some of the
obstacles there's like a a 3-foot wall
you got to push yourself over that
there's like a five-foot wall there like
I'm hoisting myself up well I put my put
my foot out blonde Dean like jumps off
of my thigh and I boost her over right
cuz there's a teamwork mentality and the
rest of our team there they decided to
go to slower pace and then you know
yoo-hoo horn you went blonde Dean pace I
met blondie a day of the race I've been
training so no but was this discussed
ahead of time yeah yeah I was like
alright good don't don't leave me please
just you and her yeah and there's so
there's no obstacles where you need I
know that I've read a little bit about
him and I've seen like pictures where
you got to have like three people
minimum to get over these certain things
or something only if if this is like
your first race and you need help over
things does your team like rally around
you to help you get over things but for
us we just had each other and a lot of
people were just kind of paired up and
then there's like you're climbing a net
wall and when I get up to the top I'm
like man this is it hits me that like if
I were to fall from this I could die
like I got to really be careful and I
got more scared and then we're going
over all types of stuff and then
there's a there's a mud hill I'd say
it's probably a six feet tall like muddy
Hill and you you climb this thing and
you get on you get on the top and you
slide down into muddy water mmm
that's like three feet deep and your run
you're like trudging across that another
muddy Hill it's taller it was it cold
the conditions were perfect I would say
it was like 74 degrees in the air
because that would be that cold would be
the worst part so I get up on the second
Hill and like we're sliding down like
man this is fun all of a sudden I'm
having fun I'm not as scared anymore and
so I slide down into that mud pit are
you like you're like saying whoa I'm not
dude you have anything that you say when
you get over I didn't have like fun
exclamations like yeah or anything like
that
I kept my redneck inner dialogue inside
but what kinds of things did you say I
went down there and I'm like my face
didn't get muddy but like my shoulders
did and I'm in I'm in up to my armpits
and I turn around and this big football
player dude like makes a huge splash and
when I turn around look at him he's he
has gone under he's got mud all over his
face and I look at him and I say you
look great and you encourage someone I
encourage someone but you also seem like
kind of making fun of them a little bit
and he looked at me and he I noticed
that he was struggling
he's like wiping his eyes with his money
hands and he was like I got it in my
eyes so he thought I was taunting him
because he was like having a moment
yeah what I was like you look great he
was like I got it all in my eyes man and
he was upset and I was like oh wait you
sounded like you were kinda making fun
of him just so you know I wasn't trying
to write but I did realize that he was
interested that moment I tried to make
up for it I was like my show up my
sleeve doesn't have any mud on it wipe
your wipe your eyes on my sleeve man and
he was like nah no no I was like dude
was blond Dean okay with this where was
she she was trying to go up the next
hill
she's like quit helping
competition and so he was like nah man
I'm like no it's it's perfectly dry just
wipe your eyes on my on my sleeve man
and I basically made him do it and he
and he did it and then he didn't say
anything to me
he just went up the hill and then so I
go up the next hill you linked him you
totally linked him I helped you
unintentionally helped a blind man on
the road you unintentionally insulted
him that's link step number he looked
great and then he forced him into doing
see he forced him into doing something
that he didn't want to do was just
Lincoln's number too high and then you
told the story and didn't realize that
well anyhow he took it link number three
and then I get up to the next hill and I
realized well I got a slide down this
third one into more mud and now there is
an inflatable wall that is well that
sounds fun that is brought down to the
surface of the mud and they force you to
submerge yourself completely and go
under so everything I did to help that
guy was immediately erased by the fact
that now we all just have to go under
this thing here yeah and that's what he
should have said and he knew that
because he told me once we got to the
top of the hill he was like this is a
lot easier than it was yesterday I was
like you did this yesterday he was like
yeah as I also you knew that you were
about to go under the go under the mud
and basically me forcing you to wipe
your face on my shirt was pointless yeah
I didn't say any of that I just kind of
slinked along yeah but I but we had to
submerge ourselves completely in the mud
and that was a fun moment but then right
after that we're running to the next
obstacle and it is a like a 45 degree
wooden triangle that was probably eight
feet tall and it had ropes hanging from
it and it was soaked because everybody
was soaked and your feet are soaked your
whole body soaked by this point and you
have to grab the rope
stand on the the wood and walk up this
wet inversion obstacle and that
was how did you do it a nearly
impossible you can have no grip well you
could grip the the rope but in your feet
hell grip but you had to lean back in
order to create more what's that called
in statics like friction well you get
you know you got a that that that force
back towards you know if you lean back
on the Rope your legs become like a
moment arm and you're like sending your
your force vector back into the the wood
so that you can get more traction and
walk but it was people were like getting
halfway up and then falling flat on
their faces and sliding back down into
all the people that were waiting now you
know Herman you get up to a goal like
this is there somebody there to make
sure you go over no well there's there's
people like on the side saying hey just
go around and if you can't do an
obstacle you have to do 30 burpees oh
but you lose a lot of pride when you got
to do the burpees 30 burpees is actually
naughty not easy I was determined to
make it up and I notice that there was
one rope that had three knots in it all
the way up as some didn't have any knots
I'm going for that one
I get half way up and then the the space
between the second knot and the third
knot was farther then I could reach with
my fingertips and I was I would grab the
rope and just slide back down and you
feel like everybody's watching
everybody's waiting for you to get over
right because it's one rope well there's
probably five people could go at a time
but there's probably 45 people waiting
as well people start backing up
embarrassing I was desperate to get over
this thing and I was holding on the rope
I was leaning back I was like really
struggling and I'm like I look at a rope
over here and it hasn't has a knot on it
and I'm like belaying over and putting
my foot on the on the on the knot and
the other rope and trying desperately to
push up and there's a guy right up there
who's helping some people over but he's
not helping me over he's just like and I
don't know if he was waiting for me to
reach out there was goes of the headband
well we all wore headbands you wear it
they give you a headband with a number
on it
it was your number then yeah that's why
I trained with a headband
do you have athletic glasses like ours
we hurt Rambis
contacts I wasn't wearing Kurt ray of
his goggles I'd missed opportunity I did
make it over but it was harrowing and
then I hung at the top and like grab
blondie and like pulled her over it was
like a survival situation I felt like
you know it's like an adult version of
like don't step in the lava kind of a
vibe what's happening there's a lot more
obstacles after that but that was the
most difficult spot for me after that
there's some there's some rings and
other monkey bars and like carrying a
lot of weight in a bucket around a
circuit and all these different things
there was even a javelin toss like a
Spartan like God so it's called a
javelin like a stick they're gentle you
can skewer somebody into what you knew
oh hey bow into people who are doing
burpees good oh you can't throw the
javelin then you're the target kill the
Burpee yours like a hay bale turns out
we ran the whole time from obstacle to
obstacle we didn't do any walking some
people are doing that if you were in
like the if you went first thing in the
morning you were liking the elite
competition people who were like doing
this for time and it's like American
Ninja Warrior type vibe but this was
like the free-for-all some people
walking everybody going at their own
pace so it wasn't the competitive run to
get across the finish line first but
once it gets to the end there's like a
rope you have to climb and that's the
that's the first thing I could not do I
never learned the techniques to climb a
rope and blondie was trying to show me
and she was having difficult times who
ended up doing the burpees and then I
saw Heidi you have to go it's probably
15 feet I'll be trouble it was
intimidating and it really my hands were
hurting so I was like I'll just do the
burpees and then I saw Kristi and the
kids and they saw me cross the finish
line and we had we got our pictures
taken they gave me the medal and there's
people there at the end they're like
hand you the metal put it around your
neck
and so I I knew that my family was
watching I felt like the whole world was
watching so I decided I'm a run up to
this guy who's handing me the medal oh
and I'm going to take a knee like a
knight so I went to take a knee nobody
else is taking a knee I guess the guy
hadn't and hadn't encountered anyone
taking a knee because as I took the knee
he tried to put the metal over mine
where my head used to be and instead
slapped me square in the face with my
metal and it's kind of what you deserve
which is a heavy metal this is an
impressively heavy metal and I know
because it hit me square in the face at
the end of my race Wow I'm pretty sure
Chrissy got this on video I hope she did
I haven't watched it back but if it is
we can we can cut to it for the video
version youtube.com slash ear biscuits
subscribe now so that kind of put a
damper on my ending this is like right
in the face and then we ran we got some
pictures but then we look we actually
ran I was exhausted I was absolutely
exhausted but blonde Dean was like let's
run back to the and and and and come
through with the rest of our team we can
support them we're all in this together
I'm like that's a great idea
but I hate you for thinking that is what
I was thinking I don't want to run back
and then we started running back and
like both of my calves I cramped up I
couldn't move I'm like I got a she like
running back I got a walk yeah do this
but we did catch up with him and we
brought them back they ended up carrying
you I recovered but we got to the rope
climb at the end and like blondie wants
to try it again she's like I've got
beans in our competition and of course
my family's still there watching and
then everybody's like try it again do
the rope climb I don't want to do this
again I didn't do it the first time and
so I had watched and I just that you
know the technique is you're supposed to
climb a rope with your leg
not your arms and I started doing it
like I hooked my my feet together and I
and then I pushed up and then I like
reached my hands up and I grabbed again
actually yeah pushed up with my legs and
then I did it a second time and then all
of a sudden I realized people were
cheering and I did it a third time and
then I did it a fourth time and I looked
up and there's the Bell and I'm bringing
the frickin Bell I climbed the frickin
rope man right awesome I'm foreseen Bret
to say that's awesome but it was
unexpectedly awesome to actually hit
that Bell like when I got down like my
family was cheering for me and then we
crossed the finish line and we all took
the pictures but and then it was over
and then we went to there's this Ruby
Tuesday's well we were we were so dirty
like coated head to foot and they had
rigged up all these garden hoses I'm
talking like probably 35 garden hoses
under this cement slab and so I go under
there and like we're all like hosing off
so then we can go into this changing
place and change and I look down and
somebody had left to hotel size shampoo
bottles in front of me and there's like
probably 50 people at different stages
of hosing themselves off
men women children there's like
post-apocalyptic except for me because I
was lathered from head to toe in every
freaking bit of that shampoo that nobody
else had so every I realized everybody
was looking at me and laughing cuz I was
like I was suds dumped like a dog taking
a bubble bath they didn't want to use it
I offered it to the people that I knew
and like Chad took a little bit and like
shampoo his hair a little bit I'm like
man i-i've never been haven't I can't
ever remember being this dirty it was
like the ram in the thicket God gave me
shampoo and I tried to share it but no
one no one wanted to let go full lather
he said I mean they were like I'll do
the thorough shower when I get home
right I was like putting it down my
pants and and then I changed to me
well I went back to my family and ate
some beef jerky and some bananas and
headed out of there but the thing that
happened that I didn't anticipate was
and it started at the rope climb and
then it continued way into the evening
and it was this I felt good I was proud
of what I done in it I know that sounds
kind of cheesy and a little weird to say
but the thing that I realized was I in
no way anticipated actually feeling that
honestly I thought I'm gonna sign up for
this thing yeah it's gonna be difficult
I'm actually I'm not surprised that I'm
nervous about doing it I'm gonna push
myself physically and I'm gonna have a
physical experience of completing
something as long as I don't get hurt
this is a success but I honestly it
didn't cross my mind that it would that
there would be an emotional component to
completing a race like this you know
people talk about completing marathons
and I totally get if you run 26 miles
and you cross the finish line like I
totally get that you might be in tears
of joy of course like but I did not
anticipate with like doing a little 3
mile 5k you know jumping over some ropes
and don't this is no big deal that it
would actually have an impact on my
self-esteem it's it was surprising to me
and it was it was kind of Awesome and I
think I just mean you're like a you're
like a Spartan I'm a Spartan junkie now
now I'd people to I've talked to people
after when the light did you get the
book
and I actually know what they're talking
about because there's this thrill of
achieving something but you know I'm not
I'm not competitive at all so any like
any of my many soccer exploits there was
I don't I don't know that I or any any
type of sport physical competition type
thing I don't think I've ever
experienced actual joy in doing it
because I was like what am I feeling
right now this is just so weird what
what is the feeling that I have that my
family just watch me climb a rope I mean
it's kind of silly
I'm a 40 year old guy ringing a cowbell
at the top of a rope and the answer was
pride you know I was brought house I was
proud and it was like it was so weird to
then realize that it was the first time
that had happened so now I gotta get my
other three that night it was like late
that night because I went back into the
kitchen to like get it like a pseudo
midnight snack because I had earned it I
mean let's be real right my watch told
me I burned eleven hundred calories
it took me an hour and a half to finish
the race that's how long it took
I was absolutely exhausted and is it the
same because you were telling me that
there's that your portion wasn't
competitive so people weren't like going
for time nobody was chuffing but the
people before that yeah in the morning
are and is it the same obstacles I think
yes see Melissa give me give me like the
I think the rest is time I say thirty
minutes I think something around there
yeah pretty that's pretty crazy yeah I
mean for me to be running the whole time
jogging if I'm not doing an obstacle and
only waiting in a couple of them it was
an hour and a half and I felt really
good about that
yeah if I haven't established that
already so that night like Lilly little
the whole Lilly comes in the kitchen she
I guess she earned a midnight snack too
and I'm like hey Lilly what did you
think about a race today she's like well
you know when you before the after the
rope climb with which the first time I
didn't do it she was like you go up to
the Rings and you know how you got to
stand there for a second
I kind of looked at your face and I
could tell that you were afraid and I'm
like I look at me I'll be the fear in
your yes I was like and I told her they
I was like I was and she was like and
then you started doing it and he like
grabbed one ring and then you swung to
the next ring and I could tell you kind
of got the hang of it and you felt
better about it and I was like I did and
then and then after you you did and I
was like did you see me do the rope and
she was like yeah yeah yeah when you
went back and did the rope that was that
was cool and their nose like a pause and
she was like I can tell you're pretty
proud of yourself and I'm like and I'm
like I am I am and it was it you know I
think it's the it's the stuff that I've
already said but it's also this thing of
like being do don't you feel like we
were taught a little bit that like being
proud of yourself or doing something is
not it's not a pure it's not a pure
thing to feel they're not in the
McLaughlin household you think oh well I
don't maybe it's a more really okay then
maybe it's just me then that I feel like
if you're gonna be proud of something
you did it's like yeah I'm proud of that
there's like a tinge oh no I don't want
to follow you don't want to be honest
getting like yeah being proud of
yourself and pride being prideful I
understand there's two different things
but I guess it bled in my sight yeah
yeah yeah so I you know I'm gonna I
think I will do it again
I encourage you to give it a shot well I
was I was reading that book there's a
book about the Iceman wim HOF and the
guy who wrote the book is talking about
this is like I read this like a year and
a half ago and always tell my Spartan
races like honey do I should really do
something like that but I don't want
they don't do that in my gym so I didn't
I didn't look at it cuz you meet you bet
you got it he wasn't gonna go out there
by myself and yeah you gotta have a
squad I don't think you can be in my
squad because I'm gonna get another
squad and beat you
Squad yeah let's do that yeah I'm gonna
take the you're gonna try to rely a lot
of game blocks to your side no I I
didn't want to do it I am legitimately
now you know me I am incredibly
competitive like competitive sports were
like a huge part of my life growing up
and so I think I definitely approach it
very differently because I never like I
I didn't I didn't think about sports and
competition in the way that I just saw
something and it was like I am going to
win at that and I and I was just like
put everything into I'm into how am I
gonna win so it was a different kind of
approach but does that mean can you
quantify can you pinpoint what's your
greatest physical feat cuz I guess I'm
saying I mean definitely in recent
history this Spartan Race was that for
me like a a personal physical milestone
last time I ran 5k was when I was on the
soccer team like we had to run a lot in
high school I'm talking that many years
ago 20 well some plus years ago was the
last time I ran anywhere near that so
well okay so speaking of 5k so I
probably told this story and like when
maybe we were way back on like the
renting caste or something but my
basketball coach was the cross-country
coach coach gage and still the
basketball coach or harness central I
don't know if he's still doing
cross-country but anyway so he kind of
got all the guys on the basketball team
to run cross-country and so I and I was
I I was an athlete so I just I was like
okay I'll do this I never really done
long-distance running but I was like
okay it means some people can do it so I
will be one of the people who can do it
okay sway I've always if somebody can do
it okay I'll be I'll do it and the
course is usually a 5k it's a 5k you
know it's the one that went around the
tobacco field and laid down the dirt
road next to school and stuff yeah
and so they were like okay well day one
you guys are all just gonna run this 5k
I got a see where you're at
yeah baseline and because that was the
competition among
just the people and someone who you're
now like half related to Bryan Lewis's
nephew I guess oh yeah yeah yeah I was
out there
he's another like tall guy like me and
so we started running and I'm like
didn't expect him to be good now he's
tall like me but I just did you know he
hadn't played any other sports that I
knew of and right and I'm like whoa he's
not gonna be me oh and okay no no
preparation no preparation for this I
don't remember this story by the way
so so I just like keep up with him I'm
like good lord this guy is fine he was
blondie kneeing you and I'm like out of
shape like baseball season was over and
I guess I was in pretty good shape for
best ball teasing whatever but like I
you know not this kind of shape
he was your height yeah he was and so
I'm just running like crazy and we get
and of course the way that the the way
that the course I kept up with him the
whole time and the way that the course
ends is it goes around one lap of the
track you come in and go around one yeah
and I was like he's not beating me ha
this is day one they want Iran did you
talk to him no Iran just running beside
Iran beside him and then didn't say a
word in the last like ten steps overtook
him and beat him you were you were you
sprinting at the end i ran the 5k in 18
minutes that's pretty good
18 minutes just to beat Bryan and which
incidentally is not even that good of a
time in cross country once like you
start like competing okay but it was by
far the best time I ever ran because I
was like my beat Bryan and that's that's
really all I wanted to prove and then
the rest of the time we during the meets
we would actually run and then we would
get around the corner and then we would
stop running and walk break out potato
chips or something and then I would get
when we would get back into we're like
the parents were watching I had kind of
just kind of jogged along not too hard
but I got to that place where everybody
was what was watching yeah
started sprinting and I would like
passed like 17 people at the very end
and come in and finish like in the
middle of the bed just so I could come
in like cheery it's a fire like just fly
and like how does this talk I have so
much energy you say Chariots of Fire but
I'm I always picture that guy in slow
motion yeah but I do look very slow
because of my limb I think but beating
Brian May in that first day that I'm
cracked in practice that may be one of
my greatest physical feats you you just
wanted you just want to let him know you
could yeah because I was thinking about
this because I once did I was thinking
about this that's you that's your
greatest physical feat like that that's
the one that's you're thinking about
well I've I've had a lot of success in
sports but I don't think of those as
like a physical right right yeah yeah
it's no no I'm saying just like a pure
physical exertion like pushing your body
to the limit have you ever been have you
ever worked out at the gym to the point
where you just vomited on your own feet
I was thinking about this and first of
all it takes a lot for me to actually
vomit you know there was the McGlothlin
streak that me and my brother and my dad
had for like I was like 40 years
combined nobody had vomited and I came
within one year we all three vomited but
anyway but that was quite a gusher the
so I don't but I've never I never worked
out so hard that I threw up I worked out
hard but I oh I came when I first
started going in the gym I came close
even because I used to go to the same
gym like they gave me they gave me a
packet like sugar water to drink well
yeah my my head between mine well and
it's like the like the circuit training
kind of thing and though you were we
were like the heartrate monitors and
stuff and like kind of burn a certain
number of calories or whatever yeah I
mean basically it's like like a couple
years ago I go to a gym but I have it I
have a trainer and we go through like a
bunch of different exercises it's
basically a mix of I mean it's all it's
all strength training but it's like so
quick and there's a bunch of it going on
together so you're also getting a cardio
workout at the same time it lasts for
like an hour and I I work out to the
like to the
I have so I have so much pride but the
bad kind of pride like I never ever stop
like and say I can't do that less
[ __ ] or something like that like I
can't there's just something in me it's
the whole Enneagram 3 thing I cannot
uh-huh you can't admit right I would not
reach the limit I will if they've told
you like you have to do this plank with
this weight on your back for a minute
after you've done this thing I'm like ok
that's what it is I'll do it
so I so it went because she just pushes
me as far as it'll go
and then I was like sore for like that
was probably as much as I pushed myself
in my 40s definitely which had before
T's ever been very long but never to do
but then there's things like I'll have
to like run across a parking lot in the
rain to get to my car and it's just like
I'm you know I got in my back issues
there's like 4 different places that my
back and get hurt and I've gotten the
knee that's got arthritis in my elbow
and my tie got tall guy issues and so I
like very stiff and very in very much
thinking don't hurt yourself
yeah I never I get going I'm like don't
hurt yourself that's the main reason I
would be scared of the Spartan Race
because like I was doing like a system
assisted pull-ups at the gym and like my
upper back thing like snaps like it's
just like the rope climb would be a
problem I think I could get to a place
where I was physically capable of it if
I figure out how to do it but I think I
I could potentially hurt myself but I
mean like you talk about running in the
parking lot I still have trouble
especially now running in the parking
lot because of this metal you know
wearing this everywhere doing it a lot
more we got to exert myself do we need
to like install obstacles like in the
office like in order for you to like get
to the bathroom you got a I'll get
blondie to come in here and yeah we can
jump over stuff yeah sure yeah I'm very
much attracted to the idea of doing
those kinds of physical challenges not
blinding I've seen blinding the because
I well I we started working out
basically as adults of the
same time like I used to you know I
would play basketball or do something
and then you kind of just run out of
time for doing that and then it's just
yeah then there was like the years of
inactivity where we were just working
really hard yeah
I mean I did convinced us to get that
elliptical machine that we had in the
Lilly basement and we used it every once
in a while I never use that what then we
just bended up putting clothes on we
would drink
we were drink slim-fast we drinks lose
weight just because it was efficient
just an efficient mode of continuing to
work but not not have any suspect and
those days we was we would we would down
to slim fast and just keep editing
videos and sometimes you one day you
showed up with an elliptical machine I
was like dude don't you know just to get
is just a physical manifestation of my
guilt I did use it oh you didn't yeah I
did more than you did
wait yeah I never used it exact you
could use it once and that statement
would be true I use it at least twelve
times but we would have a slimfast for
lunch and then sometimes we have a
slimfast for dinner as well and then we
would keep editing if that is the
commercial but and then we would sleep
at the office and then we wake up and do
it again what yeah wouldn't like a
project was was do because we didn't
have any help and yeah this is fresh in
my mind because you know I'll turn this
into a mythical society plug just
because it's near and dear to my heart
I was watching we're releasing on the
mythical Society
we're trickling out the archive of the
original rhett and Link cast show which
was a live show every Thursday night on
Ustream now it's just something you can
watch if you're a mythical society
member and so we released the first few
of those and there's one that features
that elliptical because I remember you
got it and we did a whole we did a whole
show about exercise or something and I'm
pretty sure that you were on that
elliptical that one that one hasn't been
released on to the society yet but just
looking at like that basement and seeing
how we were setting up everything you
remind you're just reminding me that
this is just a shameless mythical
society plug but no but I I definitely
have a
there as you start getting older and
you're like I got to do something to
counteract what is happening to my body
I mean the main thing that's happening
to my body is just annoying injuries or
and you don't even know what happened I
don't remember doing anything to my
shoulder I think it's just it's expired
well my I was playing soccer over
Thanksgiving and you know at my with my
nephew Nehemiah and the kids and like I
kicked a soccer ball like I messed up my
hip flexor you can't do anything like
and it I just walloped that soccer ball
and I knew something had happened and
it's still not better you got a stretch
you get it I've been stretching you got
a stretch
one minute for every year that you're
old so you got to do I got to do a 41
minutes every morning before now before
any physical activity yeah but I do like
a 20 minute stretch maybe every like
that's what that's straight as my wife
calls it now the stretch and snuggle
time with Barbara and here's but here's
my next thing because I the Spartan
thing I do recommend it I think it's I
don't know it there is a lot of risk for
injury so you got to be we need to be
careful there's less risk in triathlons
though well somebody you know that's
just endurance is that where you swim
swimming by mm see but you can do it you
can do short versions this swimming is
the problem for me I woke up in the
middle of the night thirsty is I'll get
out last night and you know I keep a big
thing of water but some have better swim
you know get thirsty
I'm Annie I'll absorb all the water and
I gotta get hydrated
what no I start drinking the water and
I'm so thirsty that I'm like I didn't
take a breath in before I started
drinking the water
I had like exhaled and then I started
drinking water and I was so thirsty that
I like I was having this inner dialogue
of like I need to breathe now but I'm
gonna get one more slurp in oh this
water and I did that and then I nearly
had a panic attack that I was gonna
droop like drown myself I just have this
like I have this fear of drowning of
drowning in your own thermos I was I was
afraid I was I can't I don't like
holding my breath man and that's why I
cannot if I'm gonna if I'm gonna drown
in a water bottle at 3 a.m.
how am I supposed to get in the ocean
and swim for a prolonged period I cannot
do that so that's the next thing I'm
going to triathlon I'm a being an
Ironman if you want to do triathlons I'm
totally down because I think it's much
less likely that I get injured because
I'm not pulling on things and crawl it's
just running biking swimming and I don't
know what the order is I think it's
biking swimming running biking swimming
running oh I'm not ready to do swim
training but straight swimming that's
something you do when you're like is 80
no do that swimming is tough like okay
so you know we used to live next to
I'm telling I like water aerobics the
pool I've never done in Sherman Oaks and
I was like I'm gonna get up in the
morning and just do swim some laps and
like I was a vet I was a good swimmer
was a competitive swimmer growing up and
was was good should have stuck with it
but so that now you would be what so a
swimmer so that I would be Michael
Phelps because I was I was actually good
I think I was actually naturally better
at it than other things that I did okay
but I didn't like the speedo and but I
love speedos now that's the weird thing
I'm wearing one right now but I was like
not a sponsor I'm gonna go bring in just
swim some laps and like I started out in
freestyle
thinking that okay this is the easiest
you know this is pretty easy like a
couple a couple of back and forth and
you're like oh this is not easy man talk
about getting your breath right you
never having to take a breath like every
time cuz I was just I was just a sprint
swimmer so like I would I would I would
go under I would dive in and I wouldn't
come up at all you know I'm saying I
would I would go get to the you do a
turn maybe take one breath and I'm down
him back and like a 50 meter or whatever
right but like you do a freestyle but
your face would stay on
yeah but the this was like I got to come
up every freakin time I'm so out of
shape I don't know how I'm in a little
bit better shape now I just started
going to the breaststroke ok Briscoe
gotta do breaststroke I gotta keep my
head above water the whole time I'm
gonna die then after that you're doing
like backstroke then after that I got
out of the pool and went home and never
did it again but it's tough it's really
tough but you water it would probably be
fun but with everything like that you
like what you're running like you get to
a place where it clicks and you're like
okay I'm normalised
mmm because with every physical activity
you hit that wall you get through that
wall then if you get your breathing and
everything and rhythm and you're if
you're not worrying so much about
competing against somebody else but
being it yourself you can kind of
maintain it for a lot longer than you
realize
I'd love I'd love to do that man let's
be triathlon buddies ourselves the
triathlon guys i shortened it to try
guys not taken well I already have a
workout partner blondie well can we be a
trio no but I the triple the triple
tribe people you can probably look up
Brian uh-huh he's probably still your
height yeah I think he's isn't he works
in an auction he's a he works for as an
auctioneer Christie's isn't that the
fancy auction place he's like in New
York City right yeah yeah New York City
New York City Brian's in New York City
working for Christie working for
Christie's Christie's auction house
candelabras and such okay that might be
difficult being on opposite side so
there it is my greatest physical feat
and I have this the show for it the
thing that slammed me in the face I'm a
Spartan I'm a Spartan I'm envious you go
i'ma give you I'm gonna give you all
types of pictures they were taking
pictures during the race and so I'd to
make a point to to make faces maybe I
could be uh I could be a Spartan
photographer photographer yeah that's
what that could be my position I got
quite a name I can't quite an angle on
things with my height thanks for sharing
in the
physical milestone experience of mine
I'll show you how to climb a rope if you
if you ever wanna learn I did it once
and there you have it
hashtag air biscuits if you got any
questions about like you know pushing
yourself to the physical limit I'm here
I'm here for you just yeah you ask away
in the meantime oh we need to we need a
recommendation oh yeah I'm gonna give
her a precondition it's a little bit
somatic in with what we've been talking
about exit effects baby I'm gonna
recommend a book that I that I finished
in two days so it's an easy read is it
ours no I think I do recommend our book
I definitely recommend the lost causes
of bleak Creek but this was actually get
out yet you have to is it out yet yeah
bleak Creek dot-com is that is the
website where you can pick that up you
can pre-order that nice plug you just
recommended our own book that wasn't my
intention my intention was to recommend
a book that is kind of an old it's a
little bit of an older book like 20
years or whatever animal farm
I read the road by rote by Cormac
McCarthy so I didn't Vigo was in the
movie yeah I didn't really was I didn't
realize how much Cormac McCarthy you
know one of the great American authors
has written a bunch of different stuff
all the Pretty Horses No Country for Old
Men like things that have been made into
epic movies but the road is like I mean
you you can it's short you can read it
and you can read it in a sitting if
you've got enough time but it is so just
speaking of bleak it is a just bleak
book you know near future
post-apocalyptic just gray dull
landscape no people and the people that
are around or just
garbage making it sound great it's
exactly the kind of thing that turns me
on so if you like if you like a book
about if you're aroused by the
apocalypse if you're aroused by a world
where there's no hope like I am if that
just scratches the right edge for you
hey listen I know you're out there I
know a lot of you are out there that's
why these books are so popular then I
highly recommend that I read and I'm
getting into now I'm reading all the
pretty courses I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
through the whole collection because
hold on you made a recommendation listen
it takes he does out of the
recommendation it just like slather is
another interesting fact about Cormac
McCarthy and I didn't realize that this
was I thought that maybe it was just a
stylistic choice for look for this
particular book but he does not use
punctuation nearly to the greet to the
degree of other people so in other words
there's no punctuation knows no
quotation marks in the entire book there
are their periods there are periods but
there are comments very few commas so
one of the things that he did is back in
the day he's old he's got he's like in
almost in his 90s at this point but this
his story goes that he was tasked with
sort of cleaning up some writers work
back when he was a young man and one of
the things he did is he like went
through and he took out a bunch of what
he called unnecessary punctuation
including a bunch of commas and the guy
was like I really like this like how
efficient this is and like now his
writing style is he'll just be like why
don't we go do a Spartan Race period
link said period Oh cuz link said is
just is a sentence yeah it can be but
usually that is odd it is at first a
little bit like oh is this am i reading
some thoughts like and then you're just
like no you know what
punctuation is unnecessary and then
there's this whole long
exchanges which is like in the road it's
a father and son talking to each other
and he doesn't say the son said or and
first of all it's just the boy and the
man it's not like they don't he doesn't
give him names you he quits he just
completely forgets saying they don't
know who's saying what no you do know
you like you do know who's saying what
because of the way that it's written
like you know when it's a two person
exchange it's usually just back and
forth but but if you get it off then
you're backwards but it doesn't happen I
don't know it was kind of a trip I loved
discovering something that's like a an
American treasure that a lot of people
already know about and then being like
oh there's like it's like when you just
it's like when you find a new television
show and you're like there are seven
seasons of this Oh dilemma oh good wreck
you know I'm so sorry I wreck I'm
excited about that
alright thanks for hanging out with us
this week you know what next week we'll
be here to speak at you again so whether
you're listening only or watching on our
YouTube channel
you're special either way there's more
where that came from
hashtag ear biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]